bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
on va parler de cannabis on va parler de
françois hollande qui n'a pas de rapport
il forcément et 3 on va parler de
frédéric thiriez ce d'emmanuel macron
donc beaucoup d'eau au sommaire de cette
émission avec pour en parler stéphane
mention de l'université de versailles
saint cordon
patrice ça va bien très bien merci
florence mercadé du barreau de
versailles il un jour tetris mustapha
larbaoui trappe du football club de
trappes et de la pharmacie des
pharmacies façon générale les gens
semblent devenir éditeur avec 1 avec un
nouveau nouvel ouvrage est publié qui
s'appelle les lucioles de yann thirion
qui est un écrivain qui heureusement oui
mais qu'ils aient déclic et
malheureusement elle est décédée il ya
il ya un mois mais il a eu le temps de
corriger les dernières épreuves du livre
et c'est un livre passionnant et c'est
le premier livre pour la jeunesse
sartre à partir de 10 ans voilà et c'est
pas comme les pôles arras est pas qu
elle c'est pas comme ces polars habituel
qui était assez rude
et là c'est très intéressant ce
passionnant c'est sûr aussi bien c'est
un livre anti anti extrémistes anti anti
fondamentalistes que ce soit chez anti
dahesh comme anti front national comme
anti anti totalitaire et mais pour
enfants et ses e-mails magnifiquement
écrit et très bien mené
attendrissant il ya de l'humour et mais
on est presque ému aux larmes
il faut vraiment recommandé à
l'intérieur les lucioles et c'est un
très très grand écrivain
voilà merci beaucoup pour ce petit
cadeau donc aux éditions évidemment la
joie dit alors on va peut-être qu'au bon
saut pourrait commencer par françois
hollande mais c'est peut-être un peu
institutionnel on va commencer par un
autre président mais un président qui
s'en va un centre hedrick des rièzes qui
vient d'annoncer que c'est le président
d'une ligue de football professionnel
conseiller d'état et qui vient
d'annoncer sa démission si je m'adresse
à vous puisque vous êtes le specis non
seulement spécial football en tout cas
des instances du football puisque vous
président de football club de trappes
que vous êtes aussi vous appartenait
aussi à la ligue
comment vous expliquer cette décision
même si vous n'êtes pas les ligues pour
fêter elle voit alors pour le coup je ne
l'exclus pas j'aurais pu éventuellement
une une hypothèse mais il était prévu
qu'il s'arrête
oui je vous l'avais prévu qu'il ne
prendrait pas un autre mandat donc il
était prévu qu'il s'arrête
et puis l'argument c'était je ne
continue pas puisque je devrai laisser
la place aux jeunes donc c'est un peu
dans l'esprit à la fois de ce qui l'a
mené dans tout ça dans toutes ses
actions au sein de la ligue
professionnelle de football et en même
temps voilà peut-être que je pourrai
éventuellement formuler c'est que d'une
part sacrée ça crée le buzz parce que
quand on l'attendait finalement ça
serait presque normal de savoir qui part
au moment des futures élections
en partant plus tôt un peu plus tôt ça
peut éventuellement créer l'événement et
ça peut ça peut lui profiter auquel cas
on peut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi ça pourrait lui servir
l'hypothèse pourrait être celle d'un
éventuellement d'aller chercher une
place ailleurs par exemple une autre
présidence la fff aujourd'hui est
présidée par m noël le graet dresser
président avant de la ligue
professionnelle à football voilà huit
dix ans d'écart donc moi c'est à ça que
j'ai pensé aux mêmes personnes ça génère
les deux un pardon ils sont en conflit
ouvert
voilà donc on peut donc imaginer que
voilà en ayant avancé comme prétexte que
c'était l'âge qu'il faisait arrêter la
vie professionnelle de football
probablement que l'âge avec une décennie
d'hommes
pourrait être éventuellement corps
sérieuse pour pour ceux qui connaissent
pas forcément bien le sujet la
différence entre la fédération française
de football et la ligue de football
professionnel alors la livre profitent
je crois que le plus simple c'est que la
fédération française de football anglais
ben la totalité des vols à bas mais
voilà même des branches comme pourrait
le dire dans l'industrie des branches ou
des secteurs où voilà alors qu' on
pourrait prendre une branche du football
français puisque la fff on à la fois le
football professionnel
le football amateur là on est
spécifiquement sur la ligue profession
les clubs ce sont les équipes de france
et la fédération française voilà ça donc
l'équipe de france on les retrouverait
plus sous l'égide de la fff que la vie
professionnelle par exemple les dossiers
qui ont été traités par la ligue
professionnelle de football
c'est essentiellement pour les
téléspectateurs c'est essentiellement
les droits télés 3d il s'est bien
débrouillé retard dirigera franchement
est-ce qu'ils auraient s'il veut faire
autant s'il peut faire un bon boulot à
la ffm de la même manière il a triplé
quadriplay je sais plus le montant
montant des droits voilà en revanche été
plantés sur les temps de la descente
entre ligue 1 ligue 2 ouais c'est ça
donc c'est à ça que je veux en venir
c'est par exemple de décembre et dossier
le vrai dossier un petit peu qui a été
qui a été un peu laborieux c'est celui
de des descentes entre la ligne 1 et la
ligue 2 sachant que ça fait des
descentes en cascade où les consignes et
que de descendre la santé pour assurer
au fond une rhinite et interclube oui
parce que en dessous c'est toujours
pareil
mais la ligue 2 étant furieux et même
même les nationaux ou les cfa parce qu'à
mon sens et ça permet de remonter ou
deux ça bloque donc l'ascenseur est
bloquée est en panne comme on dirait
éventuellement et assesseurs
footballistiques ya aussi une chose
c'est qu'ils aient une réforme je crois
de la ligue professionnelle qui fait que
le président va voir beaucoup moins
pouvoir que ce pouvoir être plus tôt et
exercé par le directeur général de la
ligue au logo wes a toujours été à peu
près le cas sauf qu'on avait un
un tiret ce qu'était voilà je crois que
le personnage ni présent way appris
appris de par sa fonction a pris après
un peu le pas mais c'est vrai que c'est
globalement ce vers ce type de
personnage qu'on va se tourner après il
ya eu d'autres dossiers dans l'histoire
de la de la vidéo dans le football par
exemple c'est vraiment son dossier
je crois qu'on a obtenu celui de
visualiser des buts est rentré dans la
ligne de démarcation si ça rentre pas
voilà donc on n'est plus dans du
football professionnel j'ai presque
envie de dire non du football le
football commercial le football showbiz
le football c'est plus cette sphère là
un avis je crois qu'il en a fait le tour
et il reviendrait à mon avis vers d une
institution plus voilà plus plus notable
est probablement une vision plus
politique des choses c'est qu'un point
de vue c'est pas d'événement sorte que
c'est bien parce que j'ai compris j'ai
notamment compris la différence entre la
ligue et l'affairé comme si je
connaissais mais parce que je vais
organiser ça parce que comme comme terry
a été spéciale au droit administratif
oui mais je voulais courir tout à fait
peut-être prendre sa place à la boue
conseil d'état juge une suprématie
serait compatible avocat qu'il est
devenu où il a quitté le conseil d'état
est devenu avocat dans un grand cabinet
d'avocats au conseil et je lisais
frédéric thiriez lorsqu'il était maître
des requêtes au conseil oui mais nous
avions dit que j'appartenais à la ligue
mais je n'en retiens la banque alors
amateurs de paris et à la fédération
française de football et la fédération
française ne veut pas renoncer c'est
vrai que en tout cas c'est assez réussit
son allié avant les séances que tout le
monde en parle
donc il serait parti comme prévu serait
qu'un peu ce que ça n'a aucun rapport
avec le fait que l'avait dit parties
jouées en chine et que maintenant il
pourra plus le défaire sa coiffure en
tout cas ça devrait nous devons parler
un peu du psg et contre il était défait
contre manchester city au quart de
finale de la ligue des champions donc il
n'y arrive pas quoi ces décès de laurent
blanc que moi je leur en blond des
joueurs de l'environnement 1
il faut bien qu'un entraîneur ça avait
quelque chose alors si sert à rien c'est
comme un chef d'orchestre enfin on peut
pas s'en passer même si un orchestre est
capable de jouer comme ça un jour si le
chef d'orchestre gabon selon sais que ça
peut pas durer on sait qu'en belgique on
veut pas vivre sans gouvernement on l'a
vu récemment tristement ben équipe de
foot il faut un entraîneur et un bon
entraîneur et l'a visiblement les rides
en blanc il gère mal ce calme et cale en
quarts de finale et j'en ai fait des
enquêtes de france aja laisse pas
exactement avec eux mêmes actes et
cameron george reeves et là c'est une
sorte de coup de folie qui fait d'avoir
tenté cet attentat quelques mais c'est
tragique
si on parlait de l'équipe france
probablement que jean-charles dirais que
c'est le président hollande qui en est
fautif au quelqu'un est responsable et
savoir quel est le président qui gère
également psg donc en gros il ya laurent
blanc est aussi un président nasser ali
fille donc il ya un président je me
demande à quel point les ja par des
dissensions au sommet j'avais une
hypothèse moi ce que je trouve que le
championnat de france le championnat
donc verser 22 équipes ouais je le
trouve plutôt plutôt faible même si on a
des excès de part et d'autre que ce soit
à nice ou à lyon de temps en temps à des
oui je n'avais pas intéressante
globalement je trouve que j'ai le
sentiment que pendant toute une année on
va s'entraîner et c'est parfait pour ça
mais c'est une hypothèse
il ya du changement de tactique j'ai eu
un très beau match du psg contre coeur
oui mais voilà de l'équipe est capable
côté les biens manager de faire des
choses magnifiques mais blyth sont
plantés face de la gestion du duc
adoriez été ridicule le la formule en
5-3-2 c'est grotesque
enfin je veux dire c'est la joie la joie
on peut se tromper mais quand il
faudrait peu de temps en temps avoir le
courage de démissionner mais ça m'était
je m'en vais penser que rendre les paris
est ce que blanc sera toujours
l'entraîneur de baisse des problèmes
parce qu'il va y avoir de toutes façons
des changements
joueurs qui vont partir ce qui peut le
sauver au contrôle de florence mercadex
qui peut le sauver c'est la défaite du
barça
après tout les meilleures équipes du
monde perdent aussi valait 1 demain donc
j'ai a perdu à la limite sont perdues au
même niveau ou à penser que ces deux
grandes équipes qui n'étaient pas prêtes
avant moi je prends part parce que moi
j'aimerais qu'on soit relâché les
sentiments que c'est au sommet que ça se
passe il ya un truc il ya un truc au
sommet parce qu'il est il y reste pour
l'horaire de deux ans a trait à ses
proches je prends le pari que ça qui
peut le sauver pendant quelques mois et
les 600000 euros qui tous les mois un
excès que je fasse je parle sous le
contrôle de florence je pense que c'est
plus compliqué à détricoter un jeu un
contrat à 600000 euros par mois convient
de russes raboliot que c'est pas très
compliqué d'envoyer voilà faut payer
mais voilà c'est pas ravi de payer on
voit rien c'était un prince parce que ce
n'est pas ce prix là aurait perdu de sa
valeur alors qu'elle adore le blog sa
valeur elle est pas énorme
le problème d'eau rien c'est qu'il a
perdu sa valeur mais cela étant pour
revenir à laurent blanc je pense pas
qu'il ait démérité je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un problème d'incohérence au
sommet un problème de conflit j'ai
l'impression que c'est vrai que c'est
pas les joies de personnes en parlerons
pas ce que c'est c'est un club de foot
je répondrais ce qui était quand même
frappant c'est que sur la pelouse y
avait quoi un milliard d'euros entre les
deux entre les deux équipes
entre manchester city et psg sur la
valeur de tous les cumuler millions
quand même donc n'ont peut-être pas un
milliard mais si je marque c'est pas
grave il ya 750 briques sur le terrain
c'était quand même et 900 way et donc si
franchement ce qu'a dit louis cruise
adore jouer halak y d'un contrat dans
fanuc millions et 1 milliard et rémunère
sur la pelouse hier sur la pelouse comme
avec des gens qui sont alors pour le psg
où ils ont fait très beau match
comme vous le disiez jean-charles et je
n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi ce
qu'ils sont capables de très bien jouer
donc je peux finir en se disant qu'à
part du coach de va
très bien joué dans le championnat même
s'il ya des équipes qui sont moyennement
bonne en france ça n'empêche que
manchester city était parfaitement alors
objectivement moins bon donc comment se
fait-il que des joueurs qui jouent
vraiment bien et de façon assez
régulière quand même cette année sur le
championnat cette année le psg a joué
régulièrement bien comment ça se fait
qu'il se retrouve un peu démuni quand il
monte la marche de l'international
comment se fait-il que des six mois
parce que ce ne soit pas que laurent
blanc et je pense qu'il ya un truc non
lanta louis alors ok un peu francis à
quelque chose de mental
moi je pense qu'il faut arriver bien au
bon moment et que c'est comme le barça
c'est à dire que à un moment les dédier
qu'il corps extrêmement bien joué
pendant un bandeau pendant une partie de
la saison mais voilà il faut être en
forme au mois d'avril le foot avec
l'analyse de flux ans sauf sur le côté
c'est assez français parce que y'a pas à
dire qu'il ya verra bio c'est une fois
sur tous ces thèmes qui sont d'argent à
des niveaux internationaux où les
nouvelles armes en bloc un peu et
laurence qui joue les mecs ya pu y a
plus la notion d'argent à ce moment là
il ya un vrai enjeu ils sont dedans ou
pas le schéma tactique est bon ou pas
ils ont été plutôt perturbée aussi par
le schéma tactique était donc été qui a
été évoqué on l'a dit le 3-5-2 donc le
schéma tactique l'entraîneur est a
priori qui fait pas forcément des bons
choix à ce moment là le la méforme
à ce moment là donc c'est vraiment tout
ça qu'on peut additionner c'est pas la
neige soit bien payé parce que
montebourg joue sa motivation à la
récitation quand ils jouent alors nous
de parler de françois hollande
est ce que c'est de sa faute si l'équipe
de france perd en tout cas il s'en est
défendu
jeudi soir à la télévision sur sur
france 2 dans une mouture est qu'une sur
de nouvelles formes
vous l'avez regardé et vous l'avez
trouvé comment qui veut commencer
mais il ya peu de gens vont regarder les
produits à peine 3 millions enfin de
vous dire qu'en gros cessé de l'odyssée
de foot n'ont cessé l'auditoire d'une
d'une rencontre de ligue 2 à peu près
honnêtement enfin bon non mais c'était
moi qui avais l impression j'ai regardé
un tout petit moins sympa tirer sa part
attiré parce que là c'est vrai que la
dernière fois quand elle était passée il
y avait sept mignon c'est quand même
très inquiétant parce que veut dire que
que de la majorité des gens ne s'y
intéresse plus nous ne ne crois pas
capable de dire quoi que ce soit et ils
ont pas eu peur parce qu'il n'y a eu
aucune annonce
voilà en deux heures d'émission ils
arrivent ils à elle défendu son bilan et
moi j'avais l'impression le peu que j'ai
regardé de ne pas être dans le même pays
parce que le entendent le président de
la république qui dit tout va bien je ne
veux pas on ne doit pas croisé les mêmes
genres ne pas pas avoir les mêmes
visiblement pas les mêmes soucis que je
trouvais ça vraiment troublant il
appelle alors pour des reproches qui a
été fait mais c'était d'être coupée au
four des règles bien démontrer enfin je
pense parce qu'il y avait certaines
cartes interpellation de la part des
gens du public qui lui posait des
questions et sur les interpellations il
répondait soit à côté en général pas
complètement
à la question et y réponde et pour ça
cette femme-là qui a perdu son fils qui
a été tuée ancien lit où elle parlait de
quelque chose de sombre ce qu'elle
voulait pas parler de son cas personnel
mais de savoir un peu que ce qu'il
comptait faire pour s'attaquer aux
racines du mal et essayer de comment on
fait pour pour éradiquer ces prêcheurs
extrêmement nocif en france et il n'a
pas répondu à la question il a répondu
chiffres il a dit il y en a deux mille
par 6 1 à 6 ans en syrie il donne des
chiffres sans répondre sur le fond de la
question qui est posée je trouve que
c'est complètement à côté et le peu
qu'il a dit était folle et sur ce cursus
ce qu'il a dit que la mosquée de brest
était fermée ce cap il m'en faut les
trouver
il a dit beaucoup de il donc c'est assez
vrai que les chiffres aussi enfin de la
croissance on avait quand même plus
l'impression d'avoir un futur candidat à
une élection qu un président vous avez
trouvé
c'est trop pas des choses parce qu'il a
parlé d'une famille doria pas parler
d'une seconde de l'avenir ni de
perspective justement non je ne sais pas
alors moustapha je vais non mais j'avais
j'ai pas vu l'arrêt piscine
je recevais le travail en nocturne je
recevais un ami de mon collègue qui est
étasuniens et je vois la conversation
que celui était et est ce que moi j'ai
entendu c'est que il n'a pas forcément
dit que tout allait bien mais que ça
allait mieux alors c'est très relatif le
mieux à l'appel de surcroît non je pense
que je n'étais pas du tout tenté de
regarder je crois que ce type d'exercice
convient très mal à ce type d'autorité
un président de la république oui ça il
ya toujours confrontation enfin aux
français les les hommes les élus les
politiques comme on dit sont soi-disant
déconnecté alors on veut les rapprocher
d'un échantillon qui n'a rien de
représentatif et puis les traits castets
en plus infiltrées des gens plutôt vous
l'année serait aussi peut-on bien avec
de l'organisation journalistique dans un
type d'émission et puis surcroît ce type
de confrontation nous montre une chose
c'est qu'elle nous confirme en effet que
les grands élus sont déconnectés de ce
qu'on appelle abusivement le terrain les
gens les vrais champs la france d'en bas
et c'est dans laquelle la vérité se
trouverait ça aussi ça reste à démontrer
je ne crois pas qu'un président de la
république qui reste dans son bureau
soit nécessairement déconnecté des
réalités quotidiennes
je ne crois pas non plus qu'un président
de la république quel qu'il soit et des
réponses systématiques à apporter à
toutes les questions qui sont posées
alors je sais pas si on l'a questionné
sur le prix d'un ticket de métro le prix
d'une baguette et dans la vallée d'elah
pas ce coup là mais alors c'est des
trucs récurrent et c'est moi c'est vrai
que entre les préoccupations
individuelles et la macro économie par
exemple il ya un fossé mais y'a rien
faut aussi comblé mon point de vue ne
doit pas être franchie et le job d'un
président de la république c'est pas ça
n'est pas de s'intéresser toujours des
riches chiffres seront plutôt meilleur
et c'est à la réalité que les gens
vivent sur le terrain mais forcément la
même ce décalage il existera toujours et
ce type d'émission mai
un relief ce décalage beaucoup plus
qu'eux quel est le problème qui est un
temps de l'opinion et un temps politique
c'est à dire que une mesure politique
pour avoir des effets il faut de trois
ans qu'apprend et le temps de l'opinion
est évidemment beaucoup plus court le
temps de l'opinion et de dvd le temps de
l'image l'image on avait un peu
l'impression rien comme que vous n'avez
c'était un super conseiller technique
qui connaissait beaucoup beaucoup de
détails de ces émissions donc voilà oui
mais ça c'est parce qu'on a tous cas par
cas se passe comme moi j'attends d'un
président laïb et quels qu'ils soient
on attend un peu une vision quelques
sodexo s'est passé c'est pas un ministre
c'est pas à partir de ministres édition
la forme de ses émissions et des
français qui sont qui représentait en
effet des catégories ça oblige s'adresse
à des catégories de français n'ont pas
toujours été quelques jeunes là je
rejoins un stéphane c'est peut-être pas
la place d'un président de la république
dans ce genre d'émission qui est très
bien pour un ministre de l'agriculture
ou éventuellement pour un premier
ministre mais pas pendant président de
la république qui doit donner une radio
appartient paraître un peu de hauteur un
peu de français très juste on dire oui
il a il a travaillé ces fiches toute la
journée mais il a perdu du temps c'est
pas ça son travail mais ça va pour la
pour l'avoir regardé si je souscris tous
et le président avant tout ce qui a été
dit alors moi je trouve qu'il trahit moi
ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est que
c'était quasiment le président en miroir
toujours de sarkozy c'est à dire qu'on
avait on avait un sarkozy qui avait
détruit mais qui avaient abîmé la
fonction présidentielle
aux dires de beaucoup parce que par
définition il était en transe y est ils
étaient un peu comme ça hyper président
et en même temps cette fois-ci hollande
alors être dépréciés à mon sens aussi
mais parle
allez il a fait preuve de beaucoup
d'empathie je trouvais qu'ils étaient
vraiment au niveau 2
il sentait bien les gens qui meurent
côté sympathique voilà est donc en terme
de en termes d'ambiance je les trouvais
très très paternaliste et en même temps
c'était le niveau des réponses qui était
pour le coup il voulait rassurer il
n'était pas convaincant donc à vouloir
rassurer en étant dans l'empathie il
n'était pas convaincant et donc du coup
ça enlever un peu de la prestance et
d'ailleurs envoyé bien que les gens qui
l'interrogeait ne se privait pas de nom
je rentrais de dumb à couper la parole
mme hamel et de la journaliste quel
niveau de plaisanter salameh donc voilà
donc j'ai l'impression que sait on si on
miroir mais à vouloir faire de l'an
quasiment de l'anti-sarko en étant
justement plus proche
on a fait tout autant par rapport à la
fonction présidentielle moi c'est ça que
j'ai retenue et en même temps il n'y a
pas tellement de gens qui l'ont regardé
donc finalement il peut encore se
rattraper mais est ce que justement
est-ce que c'est pas peine perdue quoi
on peut aller un peu il ya un peu ce
côté là pas ramer ramer contre contre le
vent pendant longtemps mais il y avait
un côté je m'excuse un peu mais vous
verrez ce sera peut-être moi je trouvais
qu'il y avait un peu une posture de
candidat est une manière de dire non je
voulais pas trop j'ai essayé de faire au
mieux pour parfaire de casse et ça sera
pire qu'un autre est ce que le manque
d'audience la déception et de la
prestation le fait que en effet il me
parle un peu dans le vide en parlant de
son bilan est-ce que ça fait pas que sa
candidature est quand même plombée
d'avant sans fin d'ici candidature il ya
il paraît un peu cramé après un peu
comme on veut et on verra ce qui se
passe dans un an mais là c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on sait que remontent les
élections aient lieu dans deux mois
on voit mal comment il pourrait s'en
sortir maintenant dans un an on sait pas
ce qui peut se passer mais voilà il peut
y avoir beaucoup de bêtises toute époque
il a enfin tout dépend encore une fois
là on oublie comme étant le front
national depuis quelques temps ce que
marine le pen a l'intelligence de la
ferme et on n'entend pas mais mais ils
engrangent les voit tous les jours avec
la complicité objective du pouvoir quand
on voit toutes ces images de casseurs
qui met paris à feu et à sang on va
parler des du mouvement et qui attaque
un commissariat de police avec les
policiers de terroriser l'intérieur et
papa un policier à l'extérieur pour
venir les sauver si c'est pas une
machine à faire voter le front national
il faut qu'on m'explique
probablement que ça plaît pour
l'éventuel primaire pour lui c'est à
dire que jusqu'à maintenant on peut dire
il est président sortant qui n'a pas à
rentrer dans l'arène
sauf que à être descendu probablement si
bas dans les sondages que youri bosco
expliqué auquel cas les primaires
pourraient s'imposer à lui
contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
penser que les rails et aux primaires de
la gauche non il a quasiment indiqué
hier qu'il n'aurait pas oui ce qu'il a
dit qu'il prendrait sa décision après
les primaires de la gauche
mais on a l'impression est celle là en
effet c'est qu'il ya une espèce de
comment dirais-je entre guillemets il
apparaît démonétisé série peut pas
rester à qui voudra se heurte un espèce
de parois lisses et glissante
à l'image d'ailleurs de sarkozy mais
l'impression que les oeufs sont
embarqués dans le même bateau et que de
toute façon il est clair que les gens
n'en veulent plus mais c'est vrai jean
charles a raison il peut se passer
tellement les choses mais je n'en avais
rien moi ou 11 mois qui viennent mais en
tout cas pour l'instant on en est là là
dessus on a terminé je parle sous le
contrôle de fleurs par tous il a pris
l'appareil a parlé quand même un moment
de d'emmanuel bacon
et la séduction mouvement en mars alors
avec des mots un peu plus sévère qu'ils
ne les avaient jusque là c'est à dire
que jusqu'ici les veut plutôt semblé
approuver la démarche des manuels macro
hier soir il a dit aux gros comme disait
chirac de sarkozy je décide d'y m'obéit
enfin c'est un peu un peu la même la
même chose le mouvement des enfin
emmanuel macron son mouvement comment
vous devez juger ça le fait que en effet
ils soient ministres et qu'en même temps
il lança une sorte même c'est pas partis
politiques pour face est un mouvement
politique en tout cas si on veut parler
de casting à la limite pour le pur pour
l'époque
je trouve qu'il présente bien les choses
parce que il n'est pas tout à fait d'un
parti politique même s'il appartenait au
parti socialiste un peu plus jeunes
aujourd'hui se présente il se présenta
finalement à nous
en disant que finalement les grandes
idées son petit droite ni de gauche sauf
peut être pour l'ump est son passage
donc on est un peu dans l'air du temps à
saint loubès
c'est je suis pas un parti politique et
en même temps je vais chercher des idées
là où elles sont et puis finalement le
dernier
le dernier chapitre de son de son
bouquin c'est je vais chercher des fonds
pour mon mouvement il était d'ailleurs
allons dans le londres pendant s'il
n'est pas encore ça ressemble et une
américaine y a une une espèce de
présidentiel à l'américaine où on fait
émerger quelqu'un qui n'était pas connu
du grand public
il n'était pas en tout cas pas des
électeurs qui n'est pas élu et donc ils
émergerait comme ça en surfant sur
l'idée de l'ump est son surf on sur
l'idée que des idées sur la sma de la
gauche
la jeunesse l'entreprise est donc
quelqu'un ramasser des fonds c'est une
manière de dire je suis capable de
collecter de l'argent je suis capable et
déjà en très grand nombre
voilà des gens qui croient voilà moi
personnellement je pense que
est-ce que c'est pas un effet de mode
comme il y en a eu d'autres et là on
reviendrait à des temps plus anciens est
ce que ce n'est pas une offre politique
aussi ça peut être une politique assez
je sais pas si la politique en afrique
lors des dmtg que je crois pas l'offre
politique le temps je vois plus une
offre 2 si vous avez juppé d'un côté
qu'est ce que le candidat de la droite
républicaine
nous sommes un maquereau qui a 30
quarante appels non pas 40 ans sont
cohérents d'entre eux n'est pas très
opposés politiquement ça peut être une
offre alternative
ce qui est extraordinaire surtout c'est
que on voit que macron il pourrait être
premier ministre un problème de hollande
réélu way ou de juppé et lui c'est quand
même assez extraordinaire
sauf que sauf que je suis l'un des plus
critiques à l'égard de maquereaux c'est
justement juppé qui est bien compris que
c'était cg pas très bon pour lui
complètement et contrairement parce que
il ira farade a dit un jour à ba oui
pourrait tout à fait être promise de
juppé il fut peu après pour en venir
hollande je pense que il a fait faisait
un peu mettre des colliers rowland en
taclant pour reprendre un terme de shoot
magron mais c'est parce que trois
minutes avant il avait il avait assommé
valls aval sont le voilà donc à chaque
fois qu'ils tapent sur na il tape sur
l'autre et madame votre avis là-dessus
mais sur macro comme ça sans la mise en
scène à plein nez le l'erreur que
brigitte a commise il a assuré une
comédie oui alors c'est un peu simple
c'est pas moi c'est logique
krekel mise en scène quelle société du
spectacle
arrêtons de minutes on est encore sur le
fond mais sur le fond moi je trouve que
ce cette personne enfin que macron
assume parfaitement son social
libéralisme
là où d'autres ont vraiment eu du mal
ont mis des années avant de l'assumer
le seul problème vous parliez d'offre
politique sans doute mais le seul
problème c'est que dans le système
institutionnel tel qu'il est construit
pour l'instant on peut pas faire grand
chose sans parti politique
souvenez-vous de ce qui s'est passé avec
jacques delors ondimba il a manqué de
courage parce qu'il s'est présenté sauf
qu'il n'avait pas le parti socialiste
derrière lui le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que macro n'a pas franchement un
parti derrière lui le centre game
d'exception c'est jusqu'à quand même
oui enfin on pourrait dire que c'est une
exception quand même parce qu'il n'avait
pas il y avait ce n'est qu'après des
républicains indépendants à l'époque je
ne faisais pas grand chose par rapport à
l'ump
oui ma famille jusqu'à enfoncer un coin
dans une
comment dirais-je oui un espace
disponible au sommet mais ce n'est pas
de revenir la pop un espace disponible
pour mac - justement ragots dans une
bouche un peu je pense qu'il a une carte
à jouer que lui joue la carte de
l'explosion du ps d'une recomposition à
gauche avec des gens qui le rejoignent
que ce soit d'ailleurs de gauche où que
ce soit de centre-droit millions de gens
qui peuvent rejoindre macron parce que
comme il est libéral humaniste et je
pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs fortes
ce soit des gens de droite ou de gauche
donc c'est un peu ce qu'ils cherchent et
je pense que si il a une qu'il ya un
vide qu'il en train de jeunes à qui lui
est déprimé vu ses deux filles c'est
votre ami ben oui de primes et aux côtes
en a bavé triomphe dans ses idées oui
oui m'enfin 0 qu'il veut être calife à
la place du calife
résumé le jeu politique un jeu de
d'ambitions personnelles venir a alerté
dès votre arrivée alors qu'il y avait eu
des sommes du même mieux votre ami
géographie il ya aussi alors toujours
c'est peut-être aussi une critique de la
politique a donc ce mouvement demie
debout derrière y'a un truc beaucoup les
médias quand même car on sait pas très
bien c'est assez amusant parce qu'on
sait pas très bien ce que c'est vous
foncez pas très bien où le situer qu'est
ce que ça veut dire est ce que c'est
important
est ce que c'est un feu de paille c'est
sûrement important parce que ça existe
et puis qu'effectivement ça fait un peu
un peu tache d'huile on en voit partout
fin
après c'est pas c'est pas peu des mots
ça se passe pas en france qui se passe
en espagne après mois la salle
commençait un peu comme ça pour des
manceaux enfin c'est ça avait démarré
quand même un peu plus vite puis il
avait j'ai l'impression beaucoup plus
d'idées derrière podemos qui en a
derrière à la nuit debout parce que moi
je suis un il pleuvait un peu moins à la
samoa et le jeu ça pas aller là-bas j'ai
pas rencontrer des gens mais tout ce
qu'on voit dans les journaux ou à la sq
on entend la radio ou ce qu'on voit la
télévision c'est pas l'impression qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'idées intéressantes qui
sortent de leur réserve sur tout mais ça
a l'air d'être des gens tous étaient
plutôt plus ou moins sympathiques et qui
a aidé brian voilà oui mais des débats
sur quoi on sait pas pourquoi je viens
voir ça me paraît un peu vain enfin
c'est un peu bizarre
justement est ce que ce n'est pas une
réponse à un débat politique est un peu
si on voit qu'on parle de rien non mais
c'est déprimant c'est une modification
des débats justement des idées peut-être
je connais quelqu'un qui est allé passer
une nuit de vous pour voir de quoi il
s'agissait
toute la nuit et donc qui me disait qu
en fait les gens avaient un profond
respect les uns pour les autres qui
avaient une écoute qui avait un échange
qui était quand même assez intéressant
est que ce qu'il en ressortait par
rapport à l'or à leurs revendications à
leurs doléances pour être dans la bonne
zone de sémantique c'est qu'ils veulent
être reconnus comme des hommes et des
femmes et pas comme des objets qu'on
utilise que ce soit de la politique que
ce soit de la consommation et plus se
recentre et l'humain
dans la société et arrêter d'être
manipulé en gros en synthèse pas chez
les bisounours mais c'est ce qu' il est
posé la question allez vous rajoutez
qu'ils aiment pas la guerre il denver
j'aime pas la misère bah oui oui ils
savent que l'eau à bouillir
systématiquement en disant on en a assez
on en a ras le bol on a envie de la
prendre
voilà la question regardez d'accord
jadran voilà il ya en effet une espèce
de sap sap a toujours existé mais enfin
c'est plus ou moins sous jacent à pas
mal de des stands période
je crois que ce mouvement n'a pas
vraiment grand chose de spontané les
choses sont parfaitement organisé par
une partie de l'extrême gauche notamment
ce qu'on voit c'est en effet alors on
parler d'offre politique là c'est une
offre politique aux antipodes de du
système actuel là c'est vraiment plaidé
en rupture je parle sous le contrôle de
france plaidait rupture par rapport à ce
système instauré avec une espèce de
comment dirais-je de conception très
horizontale des rapports humains
bon alors c'est oui la guerre c'est pas
bien la misère c'est pas bien non plus
il vaut mieux que tout le monde soit et
ce qu'il faut et tout le monde soit
heureux
enfin c'est assez génial mais c'est vrai
que il ya une espèce de d'utopie qui
fait que ça a l'air un peu gentil comme
cela mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas vu ça
à paris j'ai vu ça dans une ville de
j'allais dire de province et de région
bon il y avait dix 10 personnes qui
étaient rassemblés alors elle était
assise en plus donc j'ai un peu essayé
d'abord regarder mais je suis pas resté
toute la nuit et donc j'ai essayé
d'entendre un peu les débats alors il y
avait un type qui parlait
justement de la légalisation du canada
et puis un autre qui a parlé de choses
mais sans lien donc alors la libre
parole etc
ça c'est aussi une culture à laquelle on
n'est pas vraiment accoutumée d'enfants
france à la façon d'un speaker's corner
à londres vous pourrez instauré ça mais
je doute je doute que s'ils voulaient la
mayonnaise prenne vraiment c'est pas
podemos et pacy riddes à l'ancienne
version jeu ça c'est vrai que ça ferait
une autre activité au bois de boulogne
ce qui est très drôle l'ours et hidalgo
qui m'a surpris en bien comme en non pas
une mais non mais qui une nuit à couper
la lumière
je trouve ça assez amusant quoi de pas
ce que c'est c'est assez culotté sur
s'attend pas du tout à ce qu'elle le
fasse rien c'est un peu la lumière sur
la place de la république
c'est c'est eh c'était assez coquin
voilà c'est moskova alors parce que ça
m'évoque c'est qu'effectivement je suis
pas persuadé que ça aboutit sun ou une
offre politique ou même à de nouer de
nouvelles idées cela étant par rapport à
ce qui a été dit ici
wen la guerre c'est pas bien et la
misère c'est pas bien c'est vrai que ça
paraît être une banalité mais il faut le
dire quand même moi qu'ils ont envie de
le dire et je trouve qu'ils ont large
pour le dire et on l'a dit donc à la
limite c'est pas c'est pas tellement le
débat c'est surtout que depuis il ya des
caméras en tout cas depuis les
événements de 68 et même avant et il ya
eu des tas de mouvements comme ça
aujourd'hui le moindre truc qui se passe
dans paris il ya des caméras ça fait le
buzz fait ça fait un récit a raconté
donc là on est en train de raconter
l'idée que des jeunes n'aiment pas la
guerre et n'aime pas la misère bas après
tout il le dit c'est plutôt bien
c'est à dire que la misère ça veut dire
que la jeunesse est encore à peu près
dans ses fondements pour lui au delà de
singe pas sûr que ça aboutisse à quoi
que ce soit c'est plutôt moi ça m'a fait
penser à deux trois choses la première
ça ressemble à des printemps arabes on a
parlé tout à l'heure des résidents ça
m'a fait penser à des printemps arabes
sert qu'à un moment donné c'est quand on
veut dire dégage on va dans la rue on va
place tahir on va place mais surtout sur
toutes les places non justement c'est
que ça n'aboutira à rien j'ai commencé
par ça quand ça a pu aboutir à des
choses probablement plus terribles qu'on
a pu l'imaginer dans les prépas râble
mais c'est un peu ça l'idée c'est
hollande on dégage moi ce que j'entends
aussi hollande d'égal que les politiques
j'ai entendu
les politiques des voix largement venir
hollande les gars faut dégager tous
voilà là non c'est le président qui
l'incarnent
c'est le presseur dégage ben ali s'était
lui à ce moment là mais y avait tout ça
crie ça n'a pas la même non c'est une
image que je veux simplement voir c'est
que je suis une réflexion c'est cette
image de dire dégage et en même temps on
veut s'exprimer
moi je trouve que ça n'ira pas beaucoup
plus loin que ça et al'inverse de d'un
mouvement très pacifique ayez lui
s'exprime avec gentillesse et
bienveillant des uns les autres
moi ça m'a fait penser aussi ou
al'inverse un peu les émeutes qu'on a pu
avoir cette fois ci dans les banlieues
et des expressions différentes qui
n'aboutissent aucune aucune offre
politique mais il ya eu une expression
est un acte rationnel
voilà ac le feu est née de sa
probablement qu'on aura assez assez des
politiques qui sortira de commencer le
feu donc c'est pour dire que voilà il ya
un mode d'expression ça veut s'exprimer
il ya des médias qui les écoute donc on
en profite
samira à mon sens pas beaucoup plus loin
mais ça suppose de les écouter quand
même les jeunes
alors je voudrais qu'on parle peut-être
un mood delà de la souffrance animale
puisque c'est aussi un sujet clé et si
on parlait un petit peu quand même parce
que c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des scandales dans certains j'adore
l'album on abattoirs l'est de la baie et
vous propose d'ailleurs de voir ce fait
un reportage qui a été créé dans un
désert battoir désignent entre 2500 et
3000 porcs sont abattus chaque semaine
dans ses locaux situés à houdan
l'abattoir guillard ans est le dernier
établissement de ce type en
ile-de-france depuis 2013 les normes
européennes du bien-être animal ont été
renforcées vincent hareng directeur de
l'abattoir yvelinois s'assure du respect
de ces règles
nous mettons les ports par deux dans des
ascenseurs et des cendres dans une
concentration à 90 % de co2 qui les
endort immédiatement une fois que donc
les cochons dorment complètement
ils sont saignés donc nous on récupère
le sens et après sa part sur la chaîne
d'abattage une machine validé par la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations et par une
association de protection animale mais
les vidéos publiées sur internet en
octobre 2015 par là
association l214 ont incité l'abattoir à
prendre de nouvelles mesures
depuis les premières vidéos donc nous
avons bien regardé tout ce qu'il aurait
pu ne pas aller donc maintenant nos taux
de co2 était avant affiché sur une
petite affiche maintenant c'est une
grosse lumière verte ou rouge
si sévère on peut tuer si c'est rouge on
arrête tout parce que l'animal risque de
ne pas être passer endormie selon
vincent hareng les abattoirs n'ont aucun
avantage maltraité un animal le stress
et la souffrance altère la qualité de la
viande et entraîne donc des pertes
financières
l'établissement de 90 salariés fait
l'objet d'un contrôle annuel complet en
plus d'un contrôle quotidien de la ddpp
et une équipe de 5 personnes en
permanence qui j'allais dire respecte
régulièrement à l'abattoir deux axes
principaux la protection animale
vérifiez donc si les animaux qui
arrivent à l'abattoir donc des ports
c'était un matin mais uniquement de
porcs ne sont pas blessés ne sont pas
malades et bien entendu la sécurité
sanitaire des aliments
en cas de non respect des lois en
vigueur les établissements sont
sanctionnés des peines pouvant aller
jusqu'au licenciement du salarié
concerné ou la fermeture de l'abattoir
après la nouvelle publication d'une
vidéo de l214 fin mars
stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture a ordonné aux préfets de
procéder à des inspections dans
l'ensemble des abattoirs du pays
elles doivent être réalisés avant la fin
du mois d'avril
en un mot sur ces inspections vous êtes
tout à coup sûr puisque c'est ce qu'on
disait le
mais au rite huré meilleur lorsque le
bestiau est moins stressé mais cela dit
non cela mise à part c'est vrai que
c'est aussi on peut éviter c'est quand
même beaucoup mieux mais ce que pensait
pas qu'on va arriver de plus en plus à
une société on va manger quand même ne
serait ce que pour des raisons
économiques ou des raisons écologiques
moins de viande et plus d'insectes et
plus sincère on va pas manger on va
manger de la meilleure qu'on va manger
de la meilleure mais moins souvent le
son peut souhaiter de moins en moins de
maires dans nos assiettes c'est ça sera
une très bonne chose mais des bons
poulet des bons d'aidé des boeufs
passant sous les chars exemple le magret
monoprix pour pas le citer qui a décidé
de ne plus vendre duff de poules élevées
en batterie
c'est une bonne une bonne chose mais
c'est très bien mais moi ce que je
trouve curieux c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui achètent encore des oeufs numéro des
trois c'est ça que je trouve curieux
l'épaule ça m'a bien amusé tout courant
quand même plus c'est marqué dans la
boîte il a marqué 0 c'est bien 3 c'est
pas bon ah les données montrent trois
douzaines on peut souvent aller dans des
hôtels où le au petit déjeuner vous avez
des yeux qui sont numéro 3 invasion
ferait campagne automne mais pas
forcément non je plaisante
c'est bon faut le savoir dont il faut
informer d'abord les consommateurs
et vous avez raison de dire que voilà
moyen de souffrance meyer est ce qu'on
mange
alors est-ce que meyer est ce qu'on fume
aussi parce que le débat sur la
dépénalisation du cannabis est relancé
c'est parce qu'il est peut-être entendu
50 x ou 150 fois relancé depuis une
dizaine d'années une quinzaine d'années
alors avec des arguments qui sont cela
dit parce que quand il ya vingt ans les
premiers qui disait freud et le
pénaliser le cannabis ou vous devez
regarder avec avec des yeux de merlan
frit en disant mais cdc des dingues
céder un jeu les trafiquants en tous cas
d'avis non mais oui mais aujourd'hui il
ya quand même des arguments c'est vrai
que la pénalisation ne marche pas on est
le pays qui pénalise le plus et qui un
des pays qui pénalise le plus et qui
consomment le plus de cannabis
enfin oui il ya aussi des pays en europe
notamment hollande où ils reviennent un
peu sur cette liberté absolue tv sur
cannabis donc ça c'est un un contre
exemple que personne ne cite pas ce que
ça ça dérange un peu la doxa mai
deuxièmement je ne comprends pas bien
l'argument qui consiste à dire on sait
que c'est mauvais on sait que ça attaque
comme le cerveau tout dépend à quel
rythme on fume etc on sait que l'excès
bas et l'alcool aussi nommé d'accords
mets donc on fait des campagnes on
dépense des milliards pour dire aux gens
ne buvez pas stop halal comme l'on va
dire attendez moi qui ai vus j'ai pas
trop de whisky un peu moins sur le
pastis mais allez-y sur le cannabis
c'est complètement incohérent
soit on lâche tout tendance est
renforcée avec paris c'est un peu vrai
les bonnes mais on peut dépenser de
l'argent pour dire aux gens quand elle
cherche c'est aussi simple que ça si on
légalise de me dire allez-y tous enfin
bien sûr mais qu est ce que pourrait
dire à un enfant
ah non c'est pas bon et le vote revoir
aux jambes et soigné pourquoi c'est pas
bon qu'elle va être l'argument pour dire
de ne pas fumer puisque c'est en vente
libre en acheter l'alcool et la drogue
presque libre ou au delà de ça c'est
encore une fois le génie politique de
landes c'est pas son génie de presidents
day one
wynn holmes enfin le guen il est parfois
injustement parce qu'il est parfaitement
téléguidé c'est qu'il est socialiste
on est surtout aux l'on a le don de
trouver des trucs pour couper la france
en kata dire que c'est pas le nom mais
le cannabis est pas droit de gauche à
droite et des week-ends les robots et
voilà le prochain truc mais c'est vrai
que c'est un débat qui est enfin kimathi
qui dure depuis un certain temps et
qu'il ya des arguments alors j'entends
des arguments combes il ya aussi des
arguments pont qui sont relativement
sérieux mais jean-charles à un petit jeu
combien enfin c'est une question de
santé publique d'accord mais sur la
stricte question budgétaire par exemple
chez bien qu'il faut pas réduire ça à
une histoire d'argent mais quels sont
les moyens déployés par l'état pour
lutter contre tout cela par nos forces
de police par la justice les heures les
jours les années passées à essayer de
traquer les consommateurs parce qu on
dit ah bah oui les consommateurs
aujourd'hui sont plus sanctionnés c'est
pas vrai enfin je prends pour le coup
sous contrôle de florence enfin il ya
quand même encore y en a peu en théorie
ce en théorie la siagi quand on parle de
l'égalisation il s'agit de de réduire le
trafic était pas les jours tant
qu'acteur je pense en effet que la
meilleure façon d'assécher ou du moins
d'assécher du mieux possible
ou du moins mal possible les trafics
c'est que l'état prenne la main là
dessus moi ça me choque aussi de voir
les ravages que fait l'alcool
dans nos populations l'alcool créer des
morts l'alcool sur la route et alors
qu'on s'en émeuvent aussi un peu plus
qu'on ne le fait on dire c'est que non
c'est pas mieux mais ce n'est pas lui on
va on va tout d'un coup je pense que
s'il ya une légalisation va y avoir un
contrôle de ce qui va être vendu il y
aura peut-être moins de saloperies qui
vont pas parce qu'ailleurs
bah oui je pense que ça améliorerait la
non mais juste améliorer l'accueil parce
que sur les problématiques
oui mais voilà il ya les n'importe quoi
il ya des morceaux tous deux pneus qui
sont pendants a vu des choses quand même
assez immonde dans leur mélangé à de
l'herbe ou du site pourrait donc tous
explique lena meyer et une meilleure
qualité secourir ce serait peut-être
moins nocif aussi pour la santé par
rapport à l'evo saloperies qui peuvent
acheter sur des sur des consommateurs
oui ça
le trafic va le pousser beaucoup pour
les pas parce que ça lui rapporte
simplement ça va assécher une économie
parallèle dans certaines cités services
de poser d'autres problèmes
ça va ça aussi c'était bien là pour le
coup on va pas s'en plaint parce que
c'est s'enrichir et à s'enrichir et
s'enrichir est a priori les pharmaciens
puisqu'il s'agirait de maintenance et
angers il s'agirait le met dans un
circuit de toute façon pour pouvoir le
contrôler et quelques délais et le
contrôle et le contrôle des médicaments
et de toutes les substances souvent le
circuit pharmaceutique pour le coup est
adaptée mais
moi ça fait maintenant ouais ça fait
plus de 50 ans pas que je fumais
beaucoup j'attends j'attends la remarque
de mon voisin mais ça fait place au
concours messieurs ça fait plus de 50
ans que j'entends parler d'eux voilà de
dépénalisation oui ça fait très
longtemps des liens d'égalisation bon en
fait on a quand même franchi une étape
parce que moi mon époque c'était
pénalisé aujourd'hui par danse été
pénalisé c'était pas légalisée
maintenance est dépénalisée on peut dire
que moi mon avis est une étape vers
laquelle on n'ira pas encore d'égaler
pratiquement mais pratiquement atteint
106 la loi vise à la cession de drogue
n'est pas p certains suivent alors là
oui mais ce matin c'est à tous on parle
même de mettre une âme en maintenant
pour essayer de revenir un petit pas en
arrière mais en gros les consommateurs
j'ai parlé de mon sommet aux campagnes
trafic
par contre on a on a un sujet qui a été
évoqué c'est celui des drogues dures
c'est à dire que depuis qu'on a mis des
salles de shoot
depuis qu'on a mis la substitution
cercle est né il ya des produits qui
permettent la substitution des drogues
dures et des salles de shoot
on a une consommation d'héroïne qui a
fortement chuté d overdoses consultez
donc en termes de santé publique
ça fait vraiment du bien terme de santé
publique et en même temps en termes de
en terme de délinquance
donc c'est vrai qu'on a tout le monde a
le même objectif c'est intéressant sera
audible parce que si on regarde on voit
on peut regarder les choses où il est
logiquement à katmandou concrètement et
concret pas moi même pour être
concrètement ce qu'on veut c'est la paix
sociale dans les quartiers parce que sa
ruine quand même
alors pour le coup ça enrichit les
quartiers mais sa ruine les la santé et
sarmine le quotidien de tous ceux qui y
fit qu'au tour il donc c'est vrai que et
en même temps là c'est le pharmacien qui
parle c'est vrai que la molécule demeure
un psychotrope
alors autant l'alcool est un
antidépresseur reconnu c'est vrai que on
a plus de des faits antidépresseurs avec
l'alcool qu'on en a avec cette idée de
psychotropes et c'est vrai que ça fait
des dégâts
alors après il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs nuances il ya le taux je peux
pas rentrer dans les détails mais le le
taux de comment dire de substances à
quelle dose agit peut être ensuite sur
quelle population est ce que c'est une
population plus ou moins jeunes ensuite
les gens plus ou moins fragilisés ça
mais ça amplifie donc a priori ci avait
dit par exemple de ce qu'ils
en devenir clairement clairement il ne
deviendrait donc ça fait franchir des
étapes ça fait franchir des barrières
psychique psychotique et c'est vrai que
en termes de santé publique ces
ravageurs en même temps on a le souci de
la paix sociale on a le souci également
de l'économie parce que ça ferait des
des rentrées et surtout en terme de
cette fois ci pour les ford les forces
de l'ordre il ya un nombre incalculable
de gens qui sont sur le trafic et le
trafic n'arrête pas d'augmenter
donc il ya un coût de la police et en
qualité il ya un coût de la scène de
santé publique
voilà c'est que vous avez complété au
bout contre moi je serais plutôt contre
contre à dépeindre la dépénalisation est
d'accord plutôt contre et là pour le
coup lorsque les chats non non non je
suis pas une démonstration j-20 car ils
auraient tous les éléments c'est mon
côté ump est surprend de chaque région
mais si ce sont des arguments avancés
dans un hexagone rencontrer moi je pense
je pense mais d'un point de vue que il
vaut mieux garder la pénalisation tout
en bossant sur la prévention et ça c'est
tout mon métier de prévention que ce
soit l'alcool le tabac ou les risques
liés au football par exemple des ravages
on est bien d'accord
cette attaque aujourd'hui la politique
pénale sur ce sujet là et inefficace
total qui ne veut pas dire un échec
total capella faut pas mettre beaucoup
plus d'argent
c'est d'ailleurs ce que sur la politique
pénale qui échoue on est bien d'accord
qu'on la mette plutôt sur la prévention
une explication il ya beaucoup d'argent
à m ailleurs à mon avis mais voilà c'est
vrai que c'est l'action spéciale il
disait la distinction qu'on fait entre
drogue dure n'a pas lieu d'être
est ce que ça veut dire que c'est dans
des pagnes à lise le cannabis il voudra
aussi dépénaliser des autres drogues
nous ça n'a rien à voir c'est comme le
pacs et mariage pour tous les états
doivent se pose la question on fait
comme si en cas de dépénalisation
tout se passe comme si enfin à lui j'ai
l'impression qu'on raisonne comme ça on
va basculer dans un truc les arrêts
infernal raflé qu'elle parlait pas la
réalité
non mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette
réalité toutes choses étant égales par
ailleurs parce que ça rejoint des
questions morales l'alec les questions
relatives à la prostitution par exemple
vous êtes toujours des propositions de
loin qui veulent interdire la
prostitution
pénaliser les clients etc mais on sait
ça y est c'est fait c'est bien mais
d'accord mais toute façon on sait bien
qu'on y parviendra jamais et que plutôt
que de prendre cette question là avec
réalisme et donc avec une certaine forme
d'efficacité on l'apprend toujours par
son aspect dogmatique
c'est pas bien condamné etc c'est sûr
que c'est pas bien c'est pas bien c'est
assez mal pour tout le monde
mais sauf que c'est un fait ça c'est pas
un moyen de lutter alors on parviendra
lors de l'audition
soyons soyons réalistes que la
maintenance et le client qui va être
pénalisé la prostitution n'étant plus
interdite à la prostitution n'a jamais
été interdit
c'est pourquoi l'agencé le racolage et
et le racolage est interdit de
proxénétisme
voilà oui le racolage ne sera plus la
terre 17 clients qui sera jouée les
agressions et une activité légale ce qui
est en train de vous dire que vous êtes
pour la réouverture des maisons closes
ah oui absolument ces salles de shoot à
balai c'est pour le seul je trouve des
oui non mais c'est bien parce qu'autant
autant avoir pas la morale à avoir
comparu ce qui se fait avoir un oeil sur
ce qui se passe autant que ça se passe
aussi dans des conditions humaines à peu
près digne
plutôt que de laisser sa ligne non mais
dire que ce sera moins pire scénario
voyager un peu l'impression quand même
j'ai évoqué l'argument talent de santé
publique dont pepsico on revient à la
mode la part dont il ya un autre
argument pour moi c'est que la
pénalisation
c'est un peu comme ça ça reste quand
même la peur du gendarme elle elle
permet quand même à des beaucoup plus
jeunes d'avoir 37 crainte d'y aller moi
c'est à celle là dessus parce que ce
qu'on basculer entre guillemets ce
qu'ont les 14 15 ans je pourrais faire
des parallèles dans l'éducation
nationale dans le foot etc
il ya des ajouts à un moment donné on
sait qu'on a plus grand chose à faire je
parlerai même de la radicalité par tous
ces sujets dont on parle beaucoup
j'estime que
les jusqu'à 12 13 14 ans c'est un vrai
message qu'on continue à lancer à cela
parce qu'ils sont les plus fragiles au
niveau du développement c'est monsieur
jamais ça de l'interdît c'est juste ça
ma crainte de la dépénalisation c'est
pas que ceux qui fument consommeraient
plus ma la limite cela ils continueront
non c'est parce que j'ai de presse
donnée par contre c'est cette frontière
est tellement il rencontrerait plus tôt
et là on ferait des vrais ravages
donc c'est plus la protection et de
l'enfant en particulier à bien des
égards que je reste sur la lepénisation
l'enfant c'est vous propose 2 sur joris
totalement de sujets non non non on va
parler enfin on parlait tout à la bête
souffrance animale dali mal mais on va
peut-être pas le nom d' le restant de
top chef vous êtes un finaliste de top
chef qui de versailles nutrium du
trianon palace
je propose de regarder un sujet sur lui
et se montrer après si vous regardez ce
genre d'émission xavier pansements à 26
ans et le finaliste de top chef
second du gordon ramsay restaurant
gastronomique deux étoiles du trianon
palace de versailles
il opère le même rituel tous les matins
arrivé à 8h ils se changent et montons
cuisine la mise en place commence mon
paul
elle est bien la seule un coup mais je
paye combien donc douze semaines de
compétition top chef déjà pour vous
aviez pincemin une aventure éprouvante
et riche en apprentissages un
épanouissement perceptible pour ce jeune
cuisinier depuis gp top chef un match in
a évolué parce que j'essaie de donner
plus mon identité à moi puisque derrière
avant j'étais vraiment derrière cimolai
maintenant j'essaie vraiment de me
donner mon style de cuisine est un peu
plus créatif on va dire j'ai pris plus
de confiance en moi par rapport aux
services le rapport avec l'équipe est de
plus en plus fort c'est vrai que je suis
je suis plus en plus passionné par mon
métier je suis sous chef du restaurant
gastronomique et donc mon rôle c'est de
contrôler ce que font tous les gars avec
qui je bosse c'est à dire que jouer aux
garnitures et ben ils fuient ces
asperges se regarde si elles sont bien
les peluches et si elles sont à son bel
au niveau de la couleur le calibre et si
le goût est bon l'assaisonnement la
cuisson le matin je vous trouve comme ça
ce soir pendant le service irs pas de
problème en semaine le restaurant de 50
couverts n'est ouvert que le soir xavier
et son chef simonet annoni en profite
pour vous travaillez la carte en
fonction des saisons et des arrivages
quotidiens
une complicité un respect mutuel partagé
depuis huit ans qui a poussé le chef à
inscrire son poulain au concours top
chef
je me suis dit que j'avais un bon
candidat j'avais quelqu'un comme elle
savait que je pense qu'il était arrivé à
un certain maturité et je pense que
c'était un beau challenge pour lui aussi
techniquement c'est le meilleur moment
c'est quelqu'un qui comme m même si de
temps en temps on essaie de le faire
passer pour chacun des rappeurs encore
pour chacun d'eux un peu pour sûr de lui
en fait on va l'essayer n'est pas du
tout comme ça on est très confiants qui
va jusqu'à la fin de belle qualité pour
peut-être décrocher la finale
mais en attendant retour en cuisine
18 heures pour les derniers contrôles
qualité avant de démarrer le service
xavier brive sa brigade de douze
cuisiniers et l'équipe de service en
salle on a des clients importants la
table 4 donc il ya une personne sans
gluten 20 heures le service démarre le
second rejoint son pass annonce des
commandes vérification des assiettes
l'adrénaline augmente
attention et qu'elle me sont de rigueur
et ici c'est le passé là où je travaille
avec simonet c'est à dire que c'est un
petit peu le dernier endroit où on a un
contrôle sur onze jette un oeil sur
l'assiette
ouais marche de menus découverte avec
deux foires à deux turbos rosé de veau
rosé la passion de la cuisine pour moi
c'est venu depuis tout petit parce que
c'est vrai que mes parents il
travaillait beaucoup et j'avais besoin
de voir quand tout le monde est la seule
façon de voir c'était le bas de dîner
avec eux mois avant est ce que je
faisais je te paraît dîner un petit peu
tout seul et puis des clameurs arrivée
par voie là on se retrouve en cuisine
mais après tout sa fable une passion
qu'il espère bien honorer en décrochant
la finale de top chef 2016 lundi 18
avril et devenir ainsi le 7e gagnant de
l'aventuré culinaire c'est moi qui vais
y arriver pourquoi parce que je suis
motivé je suis pareil jusque là pour
rien 120 chefs qui est juste là qui
attend quand même
c'est important pour lui que j'avais
jusqu'au bout et je veux pas le savoir
mais par an lit ma famille c'est mon
rêve depuis tout petit c'est d'être chef
étoilé et on y croit je crois toujours
et puis comment pourquoi ça marche les
autres et pas pour moi on y va table 12
vallées doucement sous ben voilà xavier
pincement au lit souhaite de gagner ce
concours de top chef
voilà on n'a plus le temps de parler de
ça ne s'est pas très stable tout le
monde
merci merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
et puis on se retrouve très vite pour un
nouveau pass